Okay, so as you can see price was trading lower low lower high lower low lower low lower low lower high
lower low and then price broke the market structure okay right around here you can see
price broke this level i will mark it as market structure shift very simple all right
and then you want to draw your Fibonacci from the very bottom to the top of that move
where is your discounted zone below the 50 percent level okay now you can see there is no imbalance
here so we will not consider this but then there is imbalance right around this area so you can see
okay perfect but then in this case scenario you can see price respected this autoblock right
around here so let me go and remove this you could have entered from this autoblock put your
long position here your stopless right below that autoblock and you would have captured a very
nice move okay so this is an example for a buy position and before taking the buy position
of course you want to identify liquidity okay so you can see we got liquidity right around here
there you go perfect okay so now it could either be this you can see all right so there was like a
lot of liquidity here so yeah you took that into consideration consideration and then you entered
right off that autoblock and you can see that huge huge move okay very simple guys so now i will
give you examples for market structure break the continuation of the trend